at any point once a tree is built you
predict the the test observation by
passing it down the tree obeying each of
the splits it'll end up in a terminal
node and then you'll you'll
use the mean of the training
observations in that region
to to make the prediction
let's look at a slightly bigger example
a cartoon example in the in the next
slide
first of all in the slide we show in the
in the left panel here
a set of regions that couldn't be
achieved by this process so this this
one here could not be achieved because
these aren't boxes that were obtained by
sequentially splitting the data
repeatedly whereas the one on the right
can if you look at the one on the right
in conjunction with the tree on the
bottom left here you'll see that the
first split was made at t1 so there's t1
over there and that was a vertical split
right that
broke this region we've got two
variables x1 and x2 here
into a region to the left and to the
right so that's a partition
then we have a split on x2 at t2 so that
is this split over here where we divided
that box into two
and so that takes care of the left we
got region one and region two
then
on the right hand partition that we had
by splitting t1 we split x1 again at t3
so we make another vertical split here
that partitions
let's draw these in
and so that's a split at this internal
node over here
and so that makes region three on the
left
and on the right we're going to do one
more split and that's a t4 on variable
x2 that divides that into into two so
you can see in the sequential greedy
fashion we've subdivided the the space
which is just two variables here into
five different regions
now at each of the terminal nodes
we are going to approximate
the
regression function in this case by the
mean of the training observations that
end up in these terminal nodes
so what that means is if you have a test
observation and you want to come and
predict it you're going to start at the
top and you're going to query what's its
value for x1
if it's less than t1 you'll go to the
left otherwise you'll go to the right
likewise you answer each of the
questions at each of the internal nodes
and you're going to end up in one of
these regions and then your prediction
is going to be the mean in that region
so as a function you can actually
represent it nicely because it's just a
two-dimensional function by this picture
that we've got on the right here and so
it's a piecewise constant function
it's it's piecewise constant you can see
here the slices
um let's see this will be
this will be t1
is this slice over here and this will be
t2 and this function is constant in each
of the regions and that's how we're
going to represent our function at the
end of the day
okay so we've seen we've seen how we
grow a tree the question one question
arises is is how large should the tree
be
when should we stop growing the tree
well one possibility would just be to
grow as large as trees as possible right
at the extreme we could for example have
a tree that had um one observation each
terminal node or leaf
but that's that that's likely to overfit
the data producing poor test set
performance
i say why well i guess it's kind of
obvious right if you have a tree that's
so large that each observation has its
own terminal node it's going to have
training error of zero but it's going to
be adapted to that data very much and
it's going to overfit
when you give it new test data
you're probably going to have a quite
high high error as a result so
not a good idea to build as large as
three as possible
um another possibility would be to
to to stop early in other words
um
just keep splitting until it looks like
a no split helps in some sense in terms
of reducing the residual sum of squares
the criterion we saw before
but it turns out uh
this strategy can be too short-sighted
you know it's
very often stopped too early because it
looks like no good split is available
but actually if we kept splitting we'd
see a better split farther down the tree
so it turns out that a better strategy
is actually to grow a large tree
uh stopping only once a
rule like for example a type of one
that's used is a terminal node has to
have it have no fewer than five
observations say
and then with this large tree which is
probably too big we prune it from the
bottom to produce a
a tree which um
a midsize it's got um it tries to to to
balance bias and variance
and hence have lower prediction error
than either the single single node tree
or the extreme tree that has one
observation
one a node per observation so a very
bushy tree has got high variance in
right it's got high variance
over fitting the data no bias but is
overfitting and probably not going to
predict well
so actually
so what's done in in the cart software
for example or the the
tree library in r which we'll we'll
we'll see
um is this idea of building a large tree
and then pruning it back
and the the framework for that is called
cost complexity pruning or weakest link
pruning
so for that we do something actually
very much like the uh
the lasso we saw for regression we have
an objective function which is the fit
and remember the fit we're going to
measure in terms of the sum of squares
of observations are the response around
their assigned terminal nodes so our
terminals are r1 through
rm
i'm sorry r t
the the number of terminals we're going
to denote by this notation looks like an
absolute value but this means the number
of terminal nodes in the tree t so this
is the sum of squares of observations
around
the mean of
of region m
which is one of the terminal nodes and
we add them up over all the terminal
nodes so we want a tree which has small
variance but we also want to
counterbalance the size the size of the
tree so we put a penalty
on the the total number of nodes in the
tree with a penalty parameter
which will will estimate by
cross-validation again this is uh very
much
like the lasso where we had a sum of
squares of regression and we penalized
the sum of the absolute values of the
coefficient which is the complexity so
you want the coefficients to be small to
avoid over fitting here we want the size
of the tree to be small to avoid
overfitting
okay so cost complexity pruning is going
to it's going to find the best value of
alpha by cross validation
and then we're going to pick the sub
tree
in the tree or the large tree we've
grown that has a smallest value of this
criterion so summarize in the next slide
well
sorry this actually just says what i
just said and
again
yes oh okay so here's the summary of the
tree growing algorithm again this is not
something that you would normally have
to program yourself because software
which is available for example cart or
the tree software in
in r it does all this cross-validation
process for you but it's good to see
at least once what it's doing
so we build a large tree
uh with a very simple stopping rule
again
for example the um
for example we stop it when the number
number of observations in a terminal
node is some minimum number like five
and then we
uh we prune the tree to find the the
the best subtree and for that we need to
get an idea of the cost complexity
parameter the the best trade-off between
fit and tree size
so for that we use cross-validation in
this similar way that we've used it
before for regression
we divide the data into k parts kb maybe
five or ten
we set aside one part
we fit trees of various sizes on the k
minus one parts and then evaluate that
the prediction error on the part we've
left out
oh so that's clever the whole thing's
controlled by alpha then alpha decides
how big the tree is and you use cross
validation just to pick alpha exactly
right and so we choose the alpha and
we'll see cross validation curves in a
few slides but it's going to tell us a
good idea of the best value of alpha to
trade off the fit with the size of the
tree
um having chosen alpha we then go back
to the the
full tree and find the subtree that has
the the smallest i mean the tree growing
on all the training data exactly
so let's see what this looks like for
the for the baseball data
so
uh for illustration we actually took the
observation divide them into a training
set of 132 observations and the
remainder 131 in a test set
is that we want to compare the cross
validation error what we're going to get
to the test error on the separate test
set just for illustration
we build the a regression tree on the
training set using cross validation and
get idea of the the best cost complexity
parameter alpha
using six volt cross validation and by
the way six may seem like a funny number
but that's just because six divides into
132 exactly
so
um this was the firs this was the full
tree before pruning so remember we saw
the top part of this tree before right
we saw the top split
and the right split and this had all
been pruned away but now we're seeing
the the details of how we got to that
three node tree here's the the large
tree that we get the only rule being
that uh
the size of the the the term we we don't
split a terminal node that has fewer
than say five observations and that gave
us this tree with how many nodes one two
three four five six seven eight 9 10 11
12.
right but probably not all these are are
are predictive right why are some of the
arms of the tree long and some short row
uh
good question just tell me why that's
because the early splits which have
caused a big decrease in the sum of
squares they depicted by long arms and
then as we get down deeper the
incremental improvements get smaller and
smaller so that's that's depicted in the
way the the tree is represented was that
your idea or who saw who thought of that
not me it's a good idea so it's the
whoever the author of the tree growing
program in r is okay so here's the
result of cross validation which is
going to give us the prune tree so what
do we see here well we see along the
horizontal axis tree size which is the
alpha parameter so as we vary alpha it's
it's in one to one correspondence with
tree size right
uh
if alpha equals zero there's no penalty
to tree size so we get the largest tree
that we fit which was about twelve
terminal nodes
and as as we as we crank up alpha to be
bigger and bigger it puts more and more
penalty on tree size so eventually we're
forced to the left hand side here we
have actually just one there's just one
node there's no splits at all
so we're seeing the extreme from
uh the full data set to the 12 terminal
node tree
and let's look at the
the green curve is what we get from
cross validation
and it's minimized at around three
terminal nodes okay
um
well the the training error should have
said this first as we expect this is of
course we know that we can't use
training error to choose
a cost complexity
parameter because the more we fit the
better it's going to look and we see
that here right the more we fit the
lower the air
so cross-validation the other hand we
fit for a while it's it's it's it's
happy with the splits and then it looks
like it's overfitting just increasing
variance and and not helping prediction
error
the test error which we can evaluate
here because we've set aside a separate
test set
is it's roughly tracking this cv curve
it's it's minimized maybe around the
same place
so it looks like about three terminal
nodes is is good which is was the first
tree we showed exactly so it's on the
basis of this graph that we we drew that
three node tree